one two three four December 18th and 80s  sweet he called me names and called it  quits  considering the season I've got reason  to be said but considering the man I'm  glad  ring the bells and hang the mistletoe  find the Terrible's on the radio  louder now he can't say no I am feeling  free cause it's just me this year  take the train to the town and see the  tree  get some shopping done but just for me  he told me diamonds are relaxing  so I'll take three cause it's just me  this year  I'm keeping  plenty warm without him  never doubted  there's so much left to burn  as the postman and out of the snow  that's my plumber plan piano  my French Tudor made a chocolate show  [Music]  well it's just me this year  [Music]  thank you  foreign  [Music]  finally all the Thrills that I deserve  and possibly even actually  I'll find another  deer  but it's just me  this year foreign  [Music]  [Applause]  [Laughter]  [Applause]  [Laughter]